تنقل عبد الله بين سبع جهات في فتره وجيزه
في سبع قطاعات مختلفه
وبساعاتي عمل مارينا مستفيدا من نظام
العمل المرن الذي يتيح فرصا وظيفيه بساعات
مسجلا اكثر من 200 و 225,000 عقد مرن منذ
تطبيق النظام قبل سنتين
اشبه برحله ااه ما قبل الدخول في سوق
العمل اااه
تنقلت بين بين ضيعتها شركه اخرى عملت اقل
ساعه هي ثلاث ساعات عملتها خلال اسبوع
اعلى ساعه حققتها هي
قرابه همم 40 ساعه في الاسبوع محمد سار
على اقتناس الفرصه بعد تطبيق النظام
فاسس منصه تجمع اصحاب الشركات والباحثين
عن عمل في لامط العمل
ساهمت شركته بتوفير 40,000 فرصه وظيفيه
خلال فتره وجيزه والله الحمد في المنصه
عندنا لدينا اكثر من 380,000 مسجل من خلال
منصه يبحثون عن همم فرص وظيفيه من 70
مدينه حول المملكه نحن موجودين فتره 25
مدينه اليوم نعمل فيها بشكل مستمر ونغطي
همم احتياجات عمنا اكثر المستفيدين من
النظام هم النساء
اللاتي وجدنا في هذا النظام فرصه لاختيار
الوظيفه بالساعات والايام التي تناسبهن و
بنسبه وصلت ل 50% من العاملين في هذا
النمط بالاضافه الى الطلبه والموظفين
الباحثين عن زياده دخلهم الشهري
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض